[Music]
doing a musical episode where there's
this big surprise we can't tell you yeah
I mean it's a big surprise we're just
completely hiding it I don't think you
could get in there I really don't think
a million years ago guess the surprise
that's right wedding bells are ringing
in Storybrooke
during Once Upon a Time first ever
musical episode and Ichi has all the
magical onset details mama it's working
keep going you can do it we've been
asked by fans to do a musical for a
really long time we've talked about
maybe we should do it for comic-con and
like give it to our fans and let it live
there and when they approached us and
said we're finally doing a musical it we
were just like oh my god and how are we
going to do this and how do you work
that into the storyline it has to spell
so everyone breaks into song alan
zachary and michael weiner there are two
broadway guys that just had their first
show in Broadway last season I think
called first date and they've written
some original songs
powerful magic of all so we all
pre-recorded our songs first and even in
the group number for Emma and hooks
wedding we all pre-recorded our lines
that we had and then when we're
performing our songs we're singing along
to the playback that's wicked so how
they wrote this script and how they were
able to bring song into this present
time was really really unique and very
clever
when I commend them and they did a
phenomenal job of the script it's a
chance to see all of the characters that
they know and love breakouts yeah what's
better than that once upon a time the
musical episode next Sunday 7:00 central
on ABC
[Music]
you